the devnet dear hindu temple would
normally be filled with
hundreds gathered for morning prayers
but these times are anything but normal
here in thailand and especially
in india the faithful now forced to
participate through a facebook live
stream
not only is the temple community praying
for family members facing the covet
crisis there
but they've organized the delivery of
donated oxygen
nearby the tight alleys of little
india's shopping district would usually
be flowing with shoppers from across
bangkok
many who work here are part of an indian
diaspora that have lived in thailand for
generations
india's influence particularly religious
is entwined in thai
culture wanisa gua has worked in her
family shop her entire life
her father's indian her mother thai
her father is now in uttara pradesh a
state that had 40 percent of all the
covet deaths in india
last month she tries to talk to him
every day
am i worried about my father yes i am
i didn't want him to go there but he's
worried about his mother
so he wanted to go i want him to come
back
because of the third and strongest wave
of kovid to hit thailand
many here in bangkok's little india are
struggling but the community is still
strongly dedicated to doing what they
can to help people
cut in india's devastating covid crisis
indian business leaders in bangkok also
stepping in putting aside their day jobs
as they gather and send direly needed
medical equipment
there's a lot of connection between
india and thailand historically
in religious ways and many of the gods
are the same
they prepare to send another shipment of
oxygen concentrators to help alleviate
the massive strain on hospitals
and the serious lack of oxygen the
concentrators can be used for milder
cases at home
and don't need direct connection to an
oxygen supply
imagining so many people not being able
to breathe
you know just that picture going in the
head is
is something that many of us can't live
with
so while they do everything they can to
help their homeland in crisis
indian thais will have to continue to
pray via video link for their loved ones
in danger
but also pray that their situation does
not worsen scott heidler al jazeera
bangkok